mucho antes de la muerte de la reina
Todo estaba planeado después de reposar
varios días en balmoral el cuerpo de la
monarca inicia un largo recorrido este
domingo el cortejo fúnebre realizará un
viaje de 280 kilómetros por carretera
hasta edimburgo un traslado que tardará
unas 6 horas específicamente se
dirigirán al palacio de Holy la
residencia oficial del monarca en la
capital escocesa donde el ferretro será
exhibido en el salón del Trono allí
permanecerá hasta el día lunes hasta que
sea trasladado en procesión a la
catedral San Gil acompañado por el
recién nombrado Carlos III que inicia
ese día una gira por los demás países
del reino como parte de la llamada
operación
String tide más tarde en la noche se
realizará una vigilia en su honor en
compañía de miembros de la familia real
el público podrá visitar a su reina por
un período de 24 horas se espera que el
martes el ataúd con los restos de la
monarca vuela hacia Londres acompañado
de la princesa Ana única hija de la
reina llegaría a las 7 de la noche
local para luego ser transportado al
palacio de buckingham el miércoles el
férretro de la reina llegará a waves
Mister Hole donde podrá ser visitado por
el público británico durante cuatro días
la fecha decidida para el funeral de
estado de la monarca más longeva del
Reino Unido es el lunes 19 de septiembre